getting drunk or high isn't exactly easy
for lucifer but he sure knows how to
seduce anyone he wants well almost
anyone he may be powerful on earth but
just wait to see what he can do in hell
when we first meet lucifer morningstar
played by tom ellis he's grown tired of
ruling hell and he's left his kingdom
for earth he becomes the hedonistic
owner of the los angeles nightclub lux
where he spends most of his time
indulging in every conceivable desire
only a few glimpses of his powers are
initially shown and most of those are
telekinetic or telepathic in nature you
know it's a sign of how vast lucifer's
powers are that one of his minor
abilities is considered a peak super
human power by everyone else but he uses
his telekinesis as more of a parlor
trick than anything significant although
he started vehicle engines and nearby
machinery with the wave of the hand he
mostly uses the power subconsciously
while he's deep in thought this is shown
earlier in the series when lucifer
regularly levitates his pentecostal coin
basically a one-way bus token to or from
hell while brooding but also typical of
an archangel lucifer has a supernatural
physiology his basic traits are what
you'd expect to find in any comic book
hero or villain superhuman speed
strength dexterity and durability
however he isn't just an archangel but
the archangel and therefore has powers
that outclass almost every other angel
lucifer can easily throw someone across
a room with the flick of a wrist rip
doors off hinges and hold back a
three-ton fully accelerating suv with
one hand to protect chloe decker
portrayed by lauren german his brother
amenitiel played by db woodside admits
that lucifer is the most powerful of
their kind which is proven when lucifer
challenges and defeats god's right hand
his twin brother michael lucifer may
prefer a laugh but that doesn't mean
he's not terrifying when rounds to anger
that's only if the situation is
dangerous enough for him to take anyone
else seriously with humans lucifer is
like a cat playing with a mouse he
barely puts forward any effort outside
of batting away punches and using his
enemies moves against them it's always
clear that he could crush them at any
time but chooses not to true to form
lucifer would much rather talk
manipulate or seduce his way out of a
gem rather than get in a physical fight
but even when celestial beings and other
supernaturally powered creatures get
involved lucifer is still dominant on
top of beating menadil and michael two
of the most powerful angels in existence
lucifer also easily overpowers maize one
of hell's most skilled and ruthless
demons portrayed by leslie anne brandt
the fight only ended because lucifer had
decided he was finished
it's honestly impossible to say how old
lucifer is he existed even before the
creation of the universe and his
lifespan is infinite this is one of the
many reasons he tried to fill his
endless life with every perceivable
pleasure before he met chloe and made
some real friends of course he is immune
to everything that kills humans aging
negative physical conditions genetic and
contractible illnesses and poisons and
toxins they simply don't affect him
lucifer's immunity to poisons and toxins
has an interesting side effect it's
almost impossible for him to get drunk
or be affected by mind-altering
substances
though it's not for lack of trying as
the owner of lux lucifer regularly
drinks and is known for mixing a mean
cocktail but he drinks more for the
camaraderie and the taste than the
effects while he can be affected by
mind-altering substances his angel
physiology burns it out of him so
quickly he requires superhuman amounts
to just catch a buzz what humans might
see as a gift however
lucifer often mourns are you drunk i
wish
pesky supernatural metabolism keeps
getting in the way don't don't stop me
trying now
along with his immunity he is virtually
indestructible he is able to physically
withstand any amount of damage a human
or other creature could inflict multiple
times throughout the series lucifer
received bullet and stab wounds that
would easily kill anyone else he
casually tells a group of gunmen in the
pilot episode
yes well don't waste your munitions i'm
immortal
it should be noted that for a few
seasons chloe was basically lucifer's
kryptonite and physical proximity to her
would render him vulnerable to attack
and more prone to being impaired however
after this was resolved the only known
objects that could actually kill him
were the flaming sword a divine weapon
powerful enough to kill any being in the
universe and demon daggers which are
forged in hell
during his time on earth lucifer prefers
to use his beautiful human face for
obvious reasons not only is he deeply
vain but he's trying to pass for humans
so he has to look the part while in this
form it can be easy to forget he's a
fallen angel and the king of hell but
lucifer has the ability to shapeshift
into multiple versions of his terrifying
demon form this can range from simply
turning his eyes into fiery orbs
revealing his scarred demonic face or
becoming his final form as the king of
hell complete with leathery clawed wings
when lucifer doesn't physically change
shape he can still manage to push a
mental image of his demon form into any
human's mind to terrify them while
lucifer is mostly in control of his
physical appearance it is also linked
directly to his psychological state his
scarred and twisted visage is an outer
reflection of his inner turmoil and
reveals how he feels about himself
despite his devil may care attitude
lucifer actually suffers from an
enormous amount of guilt over the things
he's done and the torture he's forced to
inflict as hell's ruler this is also
reflected in his complicated love-hate
relationship with his wings
lucifer retained his angelic feathered
wings when he fell from heaven but as
the millennia passed he grew more
furious with his father when he finally
arrived on earth determined to live as a
human the first thing he did was cut off
his wings his defiance persisted until
he awoke one day to find his wings were
back and while he cut them off again
they continued to return ultimately just
as with lucifer's demon face his wings
are tied to his self-perception they
only returned after he started forgiving
himself for his sins as lucifer
begrudgingly learns to use his wings
again they grant him even more immense
power he can fly as would be expected
but he can also do this at the speed of
light or faster if he wishes it appears
as teleportation to the human eyes such
as in the episode a devil of my word
where he flies with chloe to protect her
from gunfire but despite being a fallen
angel and the king of hell lucifer's
wings give him quite a few unlikely
powers the most significant of which are
healing and resurrection while banished
from heaven lucifer still possesses the
ability to channel divine energy he can
heal humans and other celestial beings
an example is when the demon maze used a
feather from lucifer's wings on a mana
deal to fully heal a fatal wound but
lucifer also has the power to raise the
dead there are some limitations he can't
just snap his fingers and the death is
undone his wings afford him the ability
to travel and communicate between the
dimensions of earth hell and heaven so
to return the dead to life he has to fly
to hell and transport the soul back to
earth even then there is another caveat
lucifer requires a fresh body ready and
waiting or else the resurrected soul
will just wind up in the nearest newly
deceased for someone who retained so
many angelic powers one would think
lucifer would have figured out by now
that he's not a monster who is beyond
redemption sure he's the wayward son and
often clashes with the other archangels
but their exasperation with him is not
so obvious while lucifer himself isn't
too concerned about playing hooky from
running hell the natural order has been
upended so obviously there's some
tension but lucifer is still able to
contact his siblings whenever he wishes
opening up a channel of celestial
communication by praying to a particular
sibling with that said his closest
connection remains with amenadil he
regularly uses this ability to contact
him even when his big brother is
patrolling hell to cover for him lucifer
can also modify this ability to
communicate with the spirits of the dead
and he uses it to conveniently discover
details at crime scenes however unlike
his ability to tap into the celestial
communication highway his powers to
communicate with human spirits are more
limited
so you had a conversation with a dead
guy oh no he wasn't quite dead his soul
hadn't crossed the threshold
but as the king of hell he has some
demonic powers to balance out the
angelic
sure lucifer may have some angelic
powers and is actually a good guy at
heart but make no mistake he's still
well satan he hasn't been the great
tempter for millennia for nothing and
for lucifer his favorite form of
temptation is carnal it's hard to deny
he oozes sex appeal and he uses his
heightened sexuality to tempt and arouse
people naturally he often employs it to
his advantage when making a deal or
trying to ferret information out of
someone he's an equal opportunity
tempter though he mostly uses his powers
on women but he's just as happy to
seduce men when he feels like it he has
discovered an exceptionally small list
of people who are immune to a sexual
allure just chloe decker and her
ex-husband dan played by kevin alejandro
though lucifer has never attempted to
seduce dan thanks to their endless
rivalry the fact that lucifer's closest
friends aren't overwhelmed by his power
seems to suggest that the closer he is
with someone the more his power lessens
this could however also be loose for
subconsciously tamping it down as he
doesn't want to manipulate those he
genuinely respects and cares about but
what he may restrain around his friends
he unleashes on others
what do you desire tell me and it's
yours
this is the line lucifer fans have grown
familiar with he says it virtually every
episode of all his powers desire
exhibition is his most useful tool when
it comes to getting information out of
suspects or witnesses
with this power he is able to draw
someone's deepest desires and wishes out
of them and get them to verbalize them
aloud it's not quite mind control
lucifer doesn't take over their mind and
force it out of them but it operates
more like hypnosis with only chloe
managing to stay immune when lucifer
turns up the intensity he can draw out
shameful secrets dark sins or unpleasant
truths though it's rare that he pushes
hard to obtain this information lucifer
must maintain eye contact in order for
this power to work and once it's broken
so is his spell interestingly when he
was slowly turning into his full demon
form the power grew stronger and he no
longer needed eye contact to accomplish
it this lends credence to the idea that
when he's more human he subconsciously
holds himself back from prying into
someone's innermost secrets even though
he says of himself in the episode our
mojo i am and always will be master of
the mojo king of desire sultan of humans
in the most wishes and indeed he is but
more than just a king of desire he's
also the king of hell
lucifer may spend 99 of his time on
earth but despite the fact that he's
grown bored and miserable ruling over
health he's still lord of all demons and
that won't change even after years away
from hell lucifer still maintains total
control over the infernal realm in
season 4 when mid-level demons break
free of hell and infest earth in a coup
against lucifer they see his handsome
human face and perfectly tailored suit
as proof that his time on earth has made
him soft in the season finale lucifer
fully transforms into the king of hell
and compels over 100 demons to kneel
before him then immediately banishes
them back to hell he is an alpha wolf
forcing the rest of the pack to bare
their bellies while his abilities on
earth are impressive and shocking
lucifer is even more powerful when deep
in hell he can literally shape hell's
reality to his will creating illusions
and endless punishment cycles known as
hell loops he can even stop time
entirely whatever infernal powers he has
on earth are increased there a
hundredfold this also extends to
controlling the bodies and minds of
demons both individually and on mass in
essence no matter what lucifer tries he
excels as both the king of hell and
god's former favorite son the
lightbringer check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite stuff are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]
you